hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen so as a lot of you know
I'm getting married in a few weeks which
is a little bit Craig right but I'm
getting all sentimental and domestic and
making a lot of DIY fun things for my
family and friends so I want to make
something special for my parents and my
sister to really thank them for being so
supportive all my life and of course
we're putting up with me is a bit of a
bridezilla
and obviously my mind went to food so I
decided to make a little DIY cookbook
that features some of the recipes that I
grew up with that really reminds me of
being a kid at home but with a little
Abbey twist on it
I've heard enough with my friends at HP
to put together this little passion
project of mine all on my own
and it's so awesome because you know
I've been so busy planning this wedding
and they have this amazing HP instant
ink subscription service that detects
when I'm running low on ink and it'll
automatically send it to my door so I
didn't have to think about it
plus it's actually saved me money on my
ink about 50% every single month which
is awesome cuz I can actually put that
money towards my honeymoon big bonus
points about that plus the prints are
really high-quality so it's great for a
keepsake like this so I wanted to show
you one of the recipes I'm sharing with
my family for my cookbook this is my
vegan pesto pasta salad and it was
inspired by my dad's basil garden
because when we were growing up my dad
was always so proud of his basil crop so
we always made a big batch of cheese
free pesto and the funny thing about it
it wasn't because my dad didn't know
that cheese usually goes into pesto was
because my mom had this really strange
phobia of cheese we were not allowed to
have any cheese in the house growing up
believe it or not that's a whole other
video we'll get to it sometime but first
we gotta make some pesto so I'm keeping
the vegan just like my dad and it starts
with some fresh basil you don't want to
waste any of this stuff so I'm using a
combination of pine nuts which is
traditional and some almonds because I
love the flavor of the almonds so in we
go garlic of course that's also
traditional the pesto a little bit of
lemon juice
little pinch of salt some cracked black
pepper and this is my little secret
ingredient here so I've got some
beautifully ripe avocado and you don't
actually have to add any oil to this
pesto which I really like because I find
a lot of traditional pesto is kind of
oily and gritty this one super smooth so
I've cooked off my pasta and I'm losing
it gluten free pasta because my sister's
been told to kind of adhere to a gluten
free diet but honestly you can use any
kind of pasta that you have it's a short
cut pasta and whole wheat would be great
as well all right now let's get that
pesto action down so good
so I've got some chickpeas here some
colorful Tomatoes look at that so good
and then I've got some olives here
olives are really great in briny and
salty and this will make up for that
missing cheese my parents are going to
love this
or I'm gonna go in for a little taste
here we gotta make sure it's okay for
her
how about this is great so I've got a
few more weekends before my wedding so
this is going to keep me in tip-top
shape I've got lots more recipes to
create so if you like what you see of
course be sure to subscribe to my
channel follow along with Meeks i'm
going to be sharing two more of the
great recipes that are in my little DIY
cookbook leave me a comment below about
one of your family's favorite foodie
recipes and i'll see you next time on
Abbey's kitchen
you